elle domine le paysage politique de
l'allemagne et de l'europe depuis
bientôt 14 ans ça fait quatre fois
qu'elle mène au pouvoir sont partis du
centre-droit cd ou angela merkel avait
bien promis de rester jusqu'à la fin de
celui ci en 2021
mais aujourd'hui il y en a qui commence
en douter c'est la troisième fois en
quelques semaines qu'elle est prise en
public de tremblements à peine
contrôlable chaque fois il s'agissait
d'une cérémonie officielle
comme ici à berlin en compagnie du
président finlandais même scénario le 27
juin dernier lors de l'inauguration de
la nouvelle ministre de la justice avec
le président allemand frank walter
steinmeier ou encore quelques jours plus
tôt avec le tout nouveau président de
l'ukraine la chancelière assure qu'elle
n'a rien de grave
ajusteur audace maintenant son date où
tout a été dit et affirmé mme cayla
merkel en conférence de presse
je dois analyser ces épisodes je suis en
train de le faire mais je crois que ça
va passer comme 7 à paris soudainement
je suis tout à fait capable de faire mon
travail
on a connu pendant les marathons
politique nocturne souvent en europe à
bruxelles au il ya quelques jours
seulement à osaka au japon pour le jus
main elle a toujours fait étions
meilleurs font que plupart de ses
interlocuteurs l'ont élevé en allemagne
de l'est âgé de 65 ans cette chimiste de
profession se lance en politique
rapidement après la chute du mur de
berlin
elle fait ses classes aux côtés du
chancelier helmut kohl qui sera son
mentor et la nommera plusieurs fois
ministre elle ne remplacera comme
chancelière de l'allemagne du monde 2005
aujourd'hui on imagine mal l'allemagne
et l'europe sans celle qui a ouvert le
bras à un million de migrants qui a géré
d'une main de fer la crise de la dette
et qui a utilisé le poids économique de
son pays pour assurer un leadership
exceptionnel
fin 2018 ébranlé par des revers
électoraux et la perte de popularité
angela merkel annonce qu'elle quittera
la direction de son parti et qu'elle ne
briguera pas cinquième mandat
le début de la fin de l'ère merkel sans
doute on sait bien que ça va arriver au
plus tard en deux ans 21 continuera les
prochains élections par les montées mais
on sait pas encore comment va être l
allemagne après angela merkel parce
qu'on ne sait pas qui pourrait la suivre
mais qui va le faire c'est tout à fait
ouverts mais angela merkel ne partira
pas sans héritier ou héritière à la tête
de son parti cd ou une autre femme a été
élue sa dauphine à négrette cram car
npower plus encore celle qu'on a
surnommée la reine de l'europe et sans
doute très satisfaite de voir à la
présidence de la commission européenne
une autre de ses proches son ancien
ministre de la défense
ursula von der leyen le départ de cette
politicienne hors norme sera t'il
précipitée par son état de santé
les spéculations vont bon train mais une
chose est certaine elle a imprimé sa
marque comme aucune autre politicienne à
ce jour ici alexandra schatz qu'à
radio-canada montréal